your cell phone is mainly made of
plastics and metals it's easy to
appreciate the inventive process by
which those elements are made to add up
to something so useful and entertaining
but there's another story we don't hear
about as much how did we get our raw
ingredients in the first place
from the chaotic tangle of materials
that is nature the answer is a group of
clever hacks known as separation
techniques they work by taking advantage
of the fundamental properties of things
to disentangle them from each other
simple separation techniques apply to
many physical scenarios like separating
cream from milk extracting water from
soil or even sifting out flecks of gold
from river sand but not all mixtures are
so easy to unravel in some of those
cases we can exploit the differences
between physical properties within a
mixture like particle size density or
boiling point to extract what's required
take petroleum a mixture of different
types of hydrocarbons some of these are
valuable as fuels and others make good
raw materials for generating electric
power to separate them experts rely on
one important feature different
hydrocarbons boil at different
temperatures during the boiling process
each type vaporizes at a precise point
then gets separately funneled into a
container and collected as a liquid as
it cools separation techniques also take
us to the sea in some drought stricken
countries the ocean is the only
available water source but of course
humans can't drink saltwater one way to
get around this problem is to remove
salt from seawater with reverse osmosis
a process that separates waters
ingredients by size a membrane with
pores bigger than water particles but
smaller than salt particles only let's
fresh water pass through transforming
what was once undrinkable into a
lifesaver meanwhile in the medical world
blood tests are a vital tool for
evaluating a person's health but doctors
typically can't examine blood samples
until they've separated
the solid blood cells from the liquid
plasma they're dissolved in to do that
a powerful rotational force is exerted
on the test tube causing heavier
substances with higher density like
blood cells to move away from the
rotational axis meanwhile lighter
substances with lower density like
plasma move to its center the tubes
contents divide clearly and the blood
cells and liquid plasma can be tested
independently but sometimes unlike oil
sea water and blood the parts of
mixtures that we want to separate share
the same physical properties in these
cases the only way to isolate
ingredients is by chemical separation a
complex process that relies on unique
interactions between components within a
mixture and another material one of
these methods is chromatography a tool
forensic scientists use to examine crime
scenes they dissolve gathered evidence
in a gas and can monitor and analyze the
ingredients as they separate and move at
varying speeds due to their unique
chemical properties that information
then tells scientists precisely what was
present at the scene often helping to
identify the culprit separation
techniques are not just about industry
infrastructure medicine and justice one
of the most technically ambitious
projects in human history is a
separation technique aimed at answering
the fundamental question what is the
universe made of by accelerating
particles to extremely high speeds and
smashing them into each other we can
break them into their constituent parts
or ever so briefly and if we succeed at
that what's next is there a most
elementary particle and if so what's it
made of
you